Speaker 1: So I have to tell you, I absolutely
love this story.
I actually take pleasure in bringing you this
hilarious story.
As you know, Republicans are currently the
most anti-vaccine group in the United States.
There's no single factor that predicts being
against COVID vaccination.
As much as being a Republican, Republicans
love to say, Well, look at anti-vax in the
black community.
Sure, there's a history of that.
We've talked about where it comes from, but
it is Republicans that are the most anti-vaccine
group in the United States.
And for Trump, personally, this is a problem.
He believes he created the vaccines.
Now he didn't.
But Trump believes vaccines work, which they
do.
But so many of his followers don't believe
that prominent black conservative voice Candace
Owens scored an interview with Donald Trump,
in which apparently she thought that she and
Trump were going to commiserate and sort of
do their anti-vax stuff together for the audience.
But Donald Trump actually shuts it down, and
there are like five or six different interesting
things here.
Let's look at the clip, which has gone completely
viral, and then we'll talk about it.
Speaker 3: We see the corruption right.
It doesn't seem like anybody ever pays for
the corruption.
And right now, we're seeing corruption life.
Even in terms of big pharma, which is a huge
topic on the minds of mothers, especially,
you're seeing what's happening at these school
board meetings.
Where do you stand on these vaccine mandates?
And obviously, I know that you are your pro
vaccine obviously did everything you could
to get this vaccine out.
I know it was one
Speaker 4: of the greatest achievements we
did in the nine
Speaker 3: months and to be able to do that.
But now we've taken a twist, right?
It's it's gotten now we went from this is
a good thing and people should have this option
to military men.
You're going to have to resign because you're
not getting this vaccine.
Where do you stand on that?
Speaker 4: Well, I stand on forget about the
mandates that people have to have their freedom.
But at the same time, the vaccine is one of
the greatest achievements of mankind.
We would have had in 1917.
Remember the Spanish flu killed perhaps a
hundred million people?
Actually, it ended the First World War because
the soldiers was a lot of people don't know
that the soldiers got so sick.
It was a terrible thing.
There were no vaccines or would know anything.
I came up with a vaccine with three vaccines.
All are very, very good.
Came up with three of them in less than nine
months.
It was supposed to take five to 12 years and
Speaker 3: we should people have died under
COVID this year.
By the way, under Joe Biden, then under you
and more people took the vaccine this year.
So people are questioning how
Speaker 4: the vaccine worked.
But some people aren't the ones.
The ones who get very sick and go to the hospital
are the ones that don't take the vaccine.
But it's still their choice.
And if you take the vaccine, you're protected.
Look, the results of the vaccine are very
good, and if you do get it, it's a very minor
form.
People aren't dying when they take the vaccine,
but
Speaker 3: the masking of children.
Speaker 1: Now, even in this clip, Trump lies.
Trump tells a bunch of lies in this clip.
But specifically on the vaccines, he brutally
schools Candace Owens, but he's still lying.
Trump lies again about the Spanish flu.
He calls it the 1917 flu.
It was from 1918.
He says it ended World War One.
It didn't.
So he's still telling his lies in this clip
that we've heard from him so many times, but
he's way more honest than Candace Owens is
about the vaccines themselves.
But the most important lie is that Trump didn't
come up with any vaccines.
Trump had nothing to do with laying the groundwork
for many technology, which has been researched
for decades and predates Donald Trump's presidency,
predates Trump's awareness of it.
Even Trump didn't sequence the virus.
He didn't fund the sequencing of the virus.
The U.S. government under Trump pre-purchased
some doses, which many countries do, and in
fact, the Trump administration didn't even
pre-purchase enough doses.
But lies aside.
Trump is right.
The people dying are overwhelmingly the unvaccinated.
Do some vaccinated people die?
Yes, of course.
But he is completely correct about that.
And it's amazing to watch Candace Owens squirm
and move the goalposts and say, Well, yeah,
but the mandates, that's bad, right?
And Trump does.
Yeah, the bad and the masks on kids are bad,
right terms.
Yeah, those are bad.
But the vaccines work now.
What happened after the fact is incredible,
and it shows you how corroded this right wing
movement is.
Candace Owens ended up being ridiculed and
attacked by almost everyone.
The left ridiculed Candace Owens for being
so dumb about vaccines that Trump had to correct
her.
Many on the right are mad at Candace Owens
for doing an interview with Trump, which ended
up being pro-vaccine at the end of the day,
and a ton of right wingers are saying, Why
didn't she correct Trump?
Why didn't she give them the evidence that
she supposedly had?
So Candace Owens has responded.
To this by saying, now, you know, Trump's
just too old to understand how bad vaccines
are, and this is wild for two reasons, which
I'll tell you in a moment.
But let's look at what Candace Owens came
up with to explain what happened.
Speaker 3: Like sort of believing that Trump
has like sold out or that Trump is a part
of the Big Pharma syndicate.
And my honest assessment is that he just genuinely
believes that the vaccines are good.
And he believes that because he comes from
a generation like people you oftentimes forget,
like how old Trump is.
He comes from a generation I've seen other
people that are older have the exact same
perspective, like they came from a time before
TV, before internet, before being able to
conduct their independent research, you know,
and everything that they read in a newspaper
that was pitched to them that they believe
that that was a reality.
And one of those things was, you know, this
push for vaccines and believing that people
were going to die without vaccines.
And so I believe that his support of the vaccine
is genuine and it's not based in any corruption
at all.
I think he actually believes those things
and people that are saying, how is he ignoring
all the people that are being injured?
And, you know, people are sending rumble videos
and all of these, you know, websites, obscure
websites.
I believe also that he only reads the mainstream
media news.
Believe it or not, I do not believe that Trump
reads or partakes in any other news sources.
You know, I don't believe that Trump is on
the internet or you know that he necessarily
uses like, you know, the web to try to find,
you know, obscure websites.
I think that he just relies on, you know,
typical mainstream sources.
So I don't think that there's anything evil
going on there.
I just wanted to say that because so many
donors, supporters of his have are kind of
like questioning where all of this is coming
from.
And I think he just genuinely believes that
and he needs to sit down and, you know, have
a full conversation with someone.
I'm I was interviewing him in that circumstance,
but he needs to have a larger conversation
to really understand what's going on and why
so many people are just horrified.
Speaker 1: So there it is.
Trump's just too old to understand why vaccines
are so bad.
Except a ton of the very anti-vaxxers that
follow Trump are also Trump's age or close
to it, and the anti-vax stuff is spreading
on Facebook, which skews dramatically older.
How is Trump ignoring all the Rumble videos?
Candace Owens asks.
It is beyond parody, but the real issue is
donors.
She mentions donors her money, and everyone's
money is now at risk because of this.
And it's also funny that she says Trump needs
to go talk to someone about this.
I mean, I was interviewing him at the time,
but I mean a larger conversation.
What she means is she needs some other anti-vaxxer
better versed on the talking points to have
a sit down with Trump and try to convince
him, actually, the vaccines are no good.
At the end of the day, what happened is that
her donors didn't like hearing the truth from
Trump.
It destroyed her narrative.
And that's it.
And absolutely amazing, conflicting lies.
I tweeted about the fallout over the weekend.
So it seems now Trumpists love Trump because
he developed the vaccines, which he didn't
but hate him because he said the vaccine works,
which it does.
This completely triggered one time Alex Jones
at one time Donald Trump supporter Alex Jones,
by the way, the conspiracy theorist and I
want to talk about
that next.